please the bangles it goes with one
citation carry on Tom joining me today
you read both you know it's Chris Joel
now available in pill form everybody's
favorite Gary Brannen Gary Brannan burn
the city's salt the earth so that not
nothing my everyone there grow like a do
that again the room and the bouncy smell
on the internet Matt gray hello
live studio audience me I've got an
article in Wikipedia and these folks
can't see it every time to get right to
the point and a ding and the special
prize for putting the grantors which is
yeah and they we are talking about the
$100 hamburger wall hi scrap no beef in
it just on to bread buns dollars please
like away yes we're thing was all ones
this is fiber content think a single
hundred which should just look lousy and
now Gary Brennan's burger opinions yeah
too many things on top right
Oh depending on what you get alright
whimpered ah by far the superior because
it gives they're priced in pence and it
comes on a plate like a civilized person
when they can literally
Wimpy's if you go into a wimpy and
there's not many left
I'll value they come on a plate with
like a nice box Friday hey do they know
if this 20 has been invented by a chef
as abstence ibly a publicity stunt if
something like Wagyu beef or something
like those those do exist and Photoshop
like a million dollar burger with gold
leaf or something out there but this is
not that it's not actually even a
handbook is it the genetically grown in
a petri dish kind of one that they did
oh no that's that's a lot more well
right now that's a lot more expensive
oh yeah isn't it at least like 200 or
something either here's only hundred
quid to grow your own burger
even our cow I was gonna say it would
still be cheaper to to slaughter account
get a person from Hamburg Oh already one
with the right to vote in a Township
it's
well it's a fresh burger someone who has
a Birgit in his air for other burgers
plot and has the right to vote in a town
really thank you very much
yeah one hundred dollar hamburger is
certainly about food but this is this is
slang for something you might do in
general aviation is this if you sell
this oh you have jumped ahead in my
script but you know what yeah yeah I'm
gonna give you the point yes this is the
fool's gold
no that he yes so what what's a hundred
dollar hamburger or before we get into
the fall girl I saw rocks I forgot I'm
going to get a burger and I'm gonna go
in a plane to get the burger and then
eat the burger in the sky and go hahaha
sky burgers it was likely the excuse to
use your plane and flight and keep your
album I'm gonna go get a hamburger from
that place wimpy I would love to see you
try and land a plane at a wimpy bowling
alleys also that would be a 10,000 pound
hamburger Varun's we're talking Ivan
you're there's a ring road around the
bowling alley now if you were to do that
about 1:00 in the morning I reckon to be
quiet enough to get a Cessna down here
yeah ever the WIMP is not a bit Elvis
well II I forget you think he heard
about the air party as Elvis would you
know in the jungle room but my mother
mom and dad went to went to Graceland
and I think it can be described as
disappointing and monkey I went there a
long long while it looks like it comes
the sixties Council Planning Officers
self design houses it looks pretty poor
from coin size that's a really specific
gag but he's right something right it's
good but Elvis heard about this this
thing it a loaf of bread that's hollowed
out and it's full of peanut butter and
jam and banana and it's fry you've
missed it's not banana it's something
even worse for you than jelly on our ice
cream bacon I forgot the bacon it is a
entire log we're not talking like a
small I mean again you give you a point
it's not like a little one it is a full
loaf hollowed out filled with a couple
pounds of bacon and peanut butter and
grape jelly so jam look like Oh Jo
phones yeah
oh yeah haha oh yeah he's all overly
asked well it's not the children's treat
now is it roughly how many calories does
he does the fools goal all of them yeah
yeah alright Price is Right rules
process without their emotional but
there's just a letter it's it's got an
about in here I'm bear in mind the the
bread is baked with like margarine and
oil and things like that in it as well
ten thousand ten thousand I think I
think it's about a daily allowance on
he's about two thousand five hundred
fifteen thousand huh Gary wins its eight
thousand are holding them it is for I'm
stalking to the point yeah four days
worth of food every evening because
doesn't he get so it gets everyone
together goes this private jet flies
four hours or something so wherever this
places that makes it they have some
waiting in an aircraft hangar for him I
feel like because he can't waddle out of
the aircraft Management Act they sit on
the steps of the plane scoff it and then
fly oh yeah where do you get this I'd
like to try some of it ah right so it
was made by a restaurant called the
Colorado mine company in Denver Colorado
which is quite a way away from where
they were it's the Colorado in ma'am yes
yes immensely you can't do that by
mistake it's not like a it's like a big
wall put in you know or anything like
that that is generally someone to see
bread jam bacon peanut butter go for it
whatever happens out that's I'm an
American sandwich they're not the size
clean water and jelly isn't it yes it
enjoys northern but the bacon as well
are you you're pretty much right taking
taking his private jet from Graceland
president friends purchased 30 of them
oh wow
you can't on the window on that plane I
mean that's a long form you don't turn
the engines on though they just yeah we
never left the airport they invited the
pilots to join them probably well about
the lock the door there is also
something called the Elvis sandwich as
you've got some ingredients this earlier
this is a I've had one or something live
to be won in a burger place vaguely near
here
and it was a lot of food so you start
with a slice of Elvis yes because the
one I've had was banana peanut butter
bacon and got it you've got you ingredi
absolutely right peanut butter bacon
banana but so that's not as bad as it
could be them well no but murdering one
don't order the chip don't order bacon
chips either could you sleep in the
sandwich that privileged killed Elvis
and thought how could we make this more
deadly I can only give you a point it's
the sandwich that killed Elvis
yeah um not specifically would know the
many times is gonna kill delve no no
there was just one it was just a back of
a theater that waiting turn sir
I mean Elvis was known for a ludicrous
calorie intake I thought you was famous
for singing we might do anything let's
just pound it could all be on you now
don't think that a message kallen air
intake got in that Vegas residency top
I don't know over and up the
all-you-can-eat buffet what's lat holy
Kenny yeah last time oh yeah it's a
shame you story but I'm going to share
it with the world because I live me to
be it just needs to be out there last
time I went to an all-you-can-eat buffet
oh boy where I add a few before I mean
there's a pitch of like a big jug of you
know dog or a pairing on the table and
it's one world buffets its underground
there's no windows you can go in there
and not be judged and just eat whatever
y'all sure pudding with custard and
chicken secret gonna do it right
can't happen I didn't I didn't I didn't
I didn't they're on separate pudding not
only so sturdy as you so bismallah
there was one by later on they have an
ice-cream section yeah it has it right
and this was later in the evening and I
wanted some ice cream right and I
manhandled the lid off and only after
the realize it should be opened by a
staff member you know whatever my ideals
were saying why you why you take a point
and then you leave the plate and take
the tray
yeah right so it doesn't point where far
this lovely yellow sphere there's a NASA
lovely looking bowl of like lemon sorbet
and it's a little bit of chocolate on it
that's exactly what I fancy right now
popped it on my plate and I was chased
by someone because I picked up a plastic
ball pool ball that had chocolate on it
as decoration
so but looks like food near and
all-you-can-eat buffet no like the like
there's a reference increasing fuel
prices mean that Cessna now costs about
ninety five to one hundred and thirty
dollars per Hobbs hour to rent what what
is a Hobbs our the Scott imaginary tiger
in it Bradley you know II but it will be
honest crude Alan yes
flying hours always at the time you're
in the air or something like that I'm
you're off the tarmac as opposed that'd
be funny around getting on the runway
what might you measure that with Hobnobs
a big tape measure for time
don't judge me it's a way always work
for me I see it watch 37 inches with a
moon chronometer oh yeah yes what's
between AMA to call jet swing in a
minute
the clue is in the question the Hobbs
chronometer yeah it's a hub meter is a
yeah yeah I got seven hops it is a meter
that measures hours in the air but how
do you measure that how do you how do
you rent an aircraft and work out the
time it's it's been flying for is it
triggered by when the wheels go up if
you're renting the plane you want your
Hobbs meter to not run for as long as
possible because while it's running then
you're paying so what systems are using
to make sure that people don't don't
cheat it a speed meter that only comes
in above the stall speed yes you are
absolutely right that in fact we give
your point of landing gear is why I
should switch attached to London gear or
an air speed sensing vein under a wing
either way you make sure it's up does
that mean they do a lot of stalling to
get some three hours out of it well my
goal all the ways happen then flow that
me a lot of things it used to be how
long the electoral system was on how did
people get around madly gliding to land
uh more than that just doing long lines
just not turning the electrics on yeah
absolutely right flying with the
electrics off oh boy yeah that's up in
the air get going cuz once you started
you don't need the electrics overcame
engine yes spend twenty minutes with no
radar or no cigarette lighter no razor
and no radio and you forgot battery so
keep playing the music it will be fine
yeah but you keep getting those
notifications from Spotify the next time
yes yes there is also track time
committer yes of a point
what's that measure if the tachometer
like an a like in a lorry not in this
case not for a plane what they're not on
looked away unless something is very
very very or unless on a rock up outside
your megabowl you won't be laughing when
i do that in the 737 oh well yeah a
which point we smash cut to like five
days later your local news
man one 737 oh yeah I couldn't do it
it's the speed that the engine is
rotating Oh amount of rotations of the
propeller or web yes so if it's if it's
iodine runs at 2,400 rpm you can reduce
your tact I'm by making the aircraft a
bit slower and a bit safer so if you've
been out for say 20 minutes on your
normal timer and then your tuck time
says you've been out for three hours
worth they know you've been bombing
around I'm not entirely certain that's
that's the noise a little Cessna mate is
really making that noise in it yeah I'll
tell you what I'm going to plane with
you he just does that constantly with
the flying helmet yeah you're funny
funny looks at Stansted where are you
are you walking fast the queue to get
I'm chatting I'm the driver driver yes
yes which we found when you go and down
the motorway up at the end of the show
congratulations Gary we win this one
please you win a vivid I believe in your
cringing you roasted you in a visit to a
late night electrically boosted bathing
spray run by a member of boyband another
level it is game Bowers after-hours
power showers do you try writing a
description for shower that doesn't
include the word shower with that we say
thank you to Chris y'all soluble rule
together grammar then that great Ivan
comes gotten a Kleenex died
[Applause]
you